welcome to this video aiza gladiator
yeah maybe form that's either Hoffman
right yep yeah he played a very nice
game against me in the in the check been
only recently how can I make this
offbeat d6 is already a little bit of
beat maybe with f4 or something now
let's play like that that's a good
center let's take the center ok so he
wants to close the whole thing down he
seems to have a soft spot for those kind
of yeah closed positions he also plays
as I said the check benoni ok so queen
bee three or maybe I now sorry no I
don't that should let him take on f3
damage my porn structure so can't be
three is not ideal but I cannot allow
queen bee three under the capture there
and everything so maybe here in tax
class a week ok so maybe this thing
using this tempo yeah certainly that
isn't terrible for black or anything
it's just ok made some inaccurate moves
down ok maybe take and put it on the
form
trying to play against this G for Bishop
yeah so he wants to yeah it's not
exactly great thought before Matt bit
before it's just complete rubbish just
weakens weakens my position this is ok I
think some equal ish ok so it doesn't
want to go to d3 that's interesting I
thought that a move like Bishop to d3 it
was interesting a little bit earlier but
it seems that she does not does not
think that this is helping him much ok
interesting yeah very interesting KFC
for so I thought politics but I have c4
so that's not really an issue that was
not really an issue ok he's got the
bishop outside of the pawn chain which
is of course better than having it
inside of the pawn chain but it's still
from a structural point of view not the
greatest bishop ok I cannot cover the
pawn all the time and g four runs into
this check their on h3 so let's put it
up and we need a bishop endgame let's
say I'm still playing for the window so
let's see is he going before
I can I can prevent that it doesn't
doesn't hurt my chances is there any way
however for me to do something f6 okay
hmm Jack hey not sure that if f six is
good not sure my ideas OIC going 45
there may be so let's do this so that i
have rookie one I want Charlie he can
play that anyway or I mean Johnny way
immediately is what I was trying to say
so let's get this traded I asked to be
careful there that it's not that's not
so clear-cut I know that I played it a
little bit and it didn't play well in
the opening but this position is better
for white and this is it's not very
comfortable for him to play here let's
just think for just a moment this is
there better move than will get one this
is the normal move okay let's do it not
face more time
I'm not taking it just you cannot take
on a three it just leads to a clearly
better position from wide so yeah you
avoided that the question is what now
look II one now that is the that was one
idea okay one using the pin on the Eva
should win a pawn ultimately
yeah he 46 that's difficult to play
something really off beat against
because it is already a little bit
offbeat and so interesting I can also
take age 5 I don't know
but take try come on let's play a movie
I'm I'm just far too slow just decide on
one of the moves it's hard to determine
anyway what end game is better both are
much better than Wyatt but should just
play one of the two mm-hmm so let's do
this keep it keep it simple method
dr. King edge wife but he never went
there I rooks you for Wow books if I
still win the pawn check still win the
pawn on d5 but not clear that that it
net so much King f6 this is a move for
some kind of looks magna let's not be
too fancy you cannot take edge for due
to King e-form it's important little
idea check
yeah I think I should win this now with
the points meaning all of them
okay got that one flat reside was a
pretty shabby opening result but i think
i managed to to get something later in
the middle game yeah okay i just wanted
to stay off the beaten track here with
f4 I was well I was playing me for with
the intention of let's say other Kings
gambit sand and strange stuff after that
but ok this is also at least something
that I did not have before yeah this d65
looks a bit strange but this structure
is quite often be reached with the
bishop already on g7 and the bishop is
actually better on have ATM or can be
better on point of it yeah I probably
this is maybe not the best move actually
it looks completely normal but this is
an awkward reply I cannot do this yeah
after this my pawn structure is wrecked
here not this this is no problem but the
f bonds so I have to do this and now he
really gets in this play yeah ok I went
for the simple solution and it's and I
think we are talking about an equal
position here just equal I wondered if
he should should play something like
this at some point sorry bishop here
maybe this is an interesting idea given
by the engine
comp gives white a slight advantage but
I don't believe it so people should be
equally h5 yeah and here again it's not
not much happening now we trade check
yep it was interesting for him to do
this yeah that was an interesting idea
trying to do something against the G
porn but he always has to worry about
this so it's it's not clear if it's a
good idea but here I don't know I really
don't know I think why does just a bit
better this is funny the engineer it's
funny it gives them I've got stop for
stock which gives black a slight
advantage this is really really
completely completely insane because
well if white wants to draw I play like
rook t1 or t2 roped you one route 22 and
and that's it yeah Black has absolutely
no plan you can just stay so black can
never be better that's just just a funny
idea that black should be better yeah i
think it's it's it's probably equal ish
but he has to be a bit careful here you
when they have six i don't know my idea
i can tell you what my idea was I wanted
like rook t2 rook a to be for a four
that was my plan which is slow but it is
there so yeah you win Dev six I don't
know if that's a good idea ticks ticks
look to do stuff for my plan here can we
push the five here maybe that that is
status heavily condemned by the engine
the engine wants to go a five maybe
yeah now I don't have before that sets
really true that's really true now black
has to be okay with the Bishop Bishop
outside of the paunch and he's yet
active enough chat but yet it gets
tricky this d 5 is weak now and it's not
yeah here this is precise look everyone
as strong has to go back would be one
and now he's in trouble it really is
yeah I wasn't sure if I should take you
for here take g5 this is it seems the
best move at least the computer is
giving that but from here I can probably
improve I was I was thinking keep it
simple just take this but it seems to
keep it we get lunch should be seven is
strong yeah just picking my be fine but
that wins as well he cannot take on edge
for with the king check yeah and this
check this wins the whole the Hawkwind
side yeah it was a nice nice endgame I'm
satisfied with that formerly I think it
was some formerly yeah before that it
was probably about equal okay well
thanks for watching